[Musique]
rien n'est jamais définitivement acquis
il suffira d'une crise politique
économique ou religieuse pour que les
droits des femmes soient remis en
question votre vie durant vous devrez
rester vigilante ces mots de Simone de
Beauvoir furent prononcés en 1974
à la lumière du présent il nous livre un
constat terrible l'histoire des droits
des femmes à quelque chose
d'implacablement répétitif
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro des grands débats pendant une
heure nous allons revenir ensemble sur
les lois emblématiques de cette année
parlementaire nous sommes le jeudi 24
novembre 2022 c'est une journée dite
d'initiative parlementaire c'est-à-dire
qu'elle est réservée à un groupe
d'oppositions qui dispose de la séance
jusqu'à minuit ce jeudi là c'est la
France insoumise qui fait son ordre du
jour le groupe a décidé de porter un
texte unique une proposition de loi pour
inscrire le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse dans la
Constitution la parole est un Mathilde
de panneaux la présidente du groupe la
France insoumise à l'Assemblée nationale
s'il est en invariant de notre
civilisation humaine c'est la domination
des hommes sur les femmes et les
véhicules sur leur corps les États-Unis
la Pologne la Hongrie l'Italie est
d'autres pays en Europe ce sont déjà
engouffrés dans cette guerre impitoyable
réduisant les femmes à un sort misérable
nous savons qu'à chaque sursaut
réactionnaire les droits des femmes sont
en première ligne j'ai une pensée émue
pour Isabelle et agnieschka deux femmes
polonaises mortes de ne pas avoir pu
avorter dans de bonnes conditions
car collègues la restriction des droits
sexuels et reproductifs n'a jamais
abouti jamais à une diminution du nombre
d'avortements les femmes ont toujours
avorté même au péril de leur vie avant
1975 si les mieux lotis partaient à
l'étranger les autres ingurgités de
l'eau oxygénée du détergent du vinaigre
s'introduisez dans l'utérus une aiguille
à tricoter un épi de blé une brosse à
dents de l'eau savonneuse pour mettre un
terme à leur grossesse voici la réalité
des sévices que des femmes pouvaient
s'enfliger entraînant parfois leur mort
car oui la seule conséquence de la
privation des femmes du droit avorter
c'est l'avortement clandestin et le plus
souvent la mort le destin de ces lois et
pour les femmes est toujours finesse
le texte déposé par la France insoumise
vise à inscrire deux droits dans
l'inconstitution le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et le droit à la contraception le texte
a été rédigé après le recul constaté
dans certains pays comme aux États-Unis
ou en Pologne la chef de fil des
insoumis estime que c'est deux droits
doivent aujourd'hui être protégés en
France
introduire le droit à la contraception
et à l'avortement dans notre
Constitution c'est conjurer ici cette
effroi qui nous saisit lorsqu'ils les
droits des femmes font l'objet de coups
de boutoir il s'agit de donner un socle
à notre vigilance afin de parer au
basculement imprévisible dont seule
l'histoire humaine a le secret
certes nous le faisons en conscience
qu'il est demeure assez tenaces pour y
graver un droit pour l'éternité mais les
droits fondamentaux à nos yeux doivent
bénéficier de la plus grande garantie
que nous pouvons leur conférer cette
proposition de loi vise à se prémunir
d'une régression en faisant de l'attente
à ses droits l'attache la plus ardu
possible
quiconque souhaitant s'y attaquer devra
avoir les mains liées notre souhait est
clair nous ne voulons laisser aucune
chance aux personnes hostiles à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
et à la contraception
voici la question posée en creux de ce
texte souhaitez-vous laisser une chance
pour vendeur du droit à l'avortement et
la contraception si votre réponse est
non vous n'avez plus qu'à le voter car
comme nous vous trouveriez insupportable
en recul sur ses droits en revanche si
vous souhaitez leur laisser une chance
soyez clair sur le fond car à vous
entendre il n'y aurait ici que des
obstructeurs mais personne d'hostile à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
cessez d'avancer masquer quel propos les
femmes n'ont-elles pas entendu sur le
droit à disposer d'elle-même vos
amendements nous servent les pensifs les
plus écoles les femmes devraient avoir
l'autorisation de leur compagnon de leur
mari pour avorter les mineurs devraient
être privés de ce droit l'embryon et le
fœtus serait des enfants à naître
l'avortement devrait être présenté comme
un drame oui l'histoire est quelque
chose de terriblement répétitif des
années 70 à nos jours la teneur des
débats n'a pas changé
ici même les frontières s'effacent le
prétendu cordon sanitaire qui sépare les
différentes nuances de droites devient
lâche ainsi les amendements et leurs se
confondent avec ceux de l'extrême droite
tous deux réunis dans une même passion
en style droit des femmes un continuum
misogyne se dessine sous nos yeux
vos résistances n'ont rien d'original
tant le contrôle du corps des femmes
s'inscrit dans une histoire millénaire
sachez que la bigoterie parlementaire
est un oxymore le sort des femmes n'a
pas à dépendre de vos conservatismes
personnels vous pensez appartenir à vos
convictions quand vos convictions
n'appartiennent qu'à la longue histoire
de la domination masculine ailleurs vos
avatars voient leur monde mourir et
tenter d'y donner un dernier sursis
c'est donc dans ce moment précis de
l'histoire que le Parlement sonnerait à
voter cette proposition de loi en
introduisant ses droits dans la
Constitution la France s'illustrerait
comme une nation pionnière en matière
des droits des femmes c'est avec cette
certitude que nous avons collectivement
réfléchi aux différentes rédactions
possibles de ce texte il s'agit d'un
travail transportant et je tiens ici à
saluer à remercier mes collègues
monsieur Balanant madame violent madame
Baptiste Madame faussillon et Monsieur
Yordanov
introduire le droit à la contraception
et à l'avortement dans notre
Constitution c'est aussi formuler la
promesse suivante aux nouvelles
générations vos mères ne seront pas
mieux protégés que vous c'est fait acte
de progrès humain en affirmant
collectivement à la nécessité de ses
droits c'est une manière de briser enfin
cette partition historique entre la
sphère privée et politique voulant que
les droits sexuels et reproductifs
soient un propre à entrer dans notre
texte suprême les droits à l'avortement
et à la contraception vont de pair et ne
sont pas une affaire de bonne femme ces
droits ne doivent être cantonnés à la
sphère du domicile assignant les femmes
à des tâches silencieuses de
reproduction sociale non les droits
sexuels et reproductifs sont la
condition de possibilité de notre
communauté politique et relève de
l'égalité et de la citoyenneté
collègue
j'achève en vous disant que je ne suis
pas venu seul ici une pétition à d'ores
et déjà recueilli 160 000 signatures
citoyennes pour l'inscription de ses
droits dans la Constitution
car derrière une proposition de loi il y
a toujours une foule une foule guidée
par une inlassable quête d'émancipation
de maîtrise de sa propre existence une
foule de femmes et d'hommes deux
militantes infatigables d'associations
et de collectifs sans lesquels un droit
n'a fleur pas auprès du grand nombre
comme une nécessité
collègue aujourd'hui nous pouvons tenir
le fil de l'histoire le vote de ce texte
sera je l'espère une forme d'hommage à
leur juste combat je vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement soutient la proposition
de loi constitutionnelle de la France
insoumise à la tribune le garde des
sceaux
Eric Dupont-Moretti défend une réforme
indispensable gravée dans le marbre de
la Constitution un droit essentiel
le Gouvernement est favorable à
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG dans
notre Constitution
l'histoire fourmille d'exemples de
liberté fondamentale que l'on croyait
acquise et qui pourtant ont été rayés
d'un trait de plumes par les événements
les crises ou les lames de fond
et c'est encore plus vrai lorsqu'il
s'agit des droits des femmes parce que
nos sociétés les ont en réalité bafoués
durant des siècles
les événements qui se déroulent hors de
nos frontières
partout dans le monde
nous le démontre avec force et acuité
c'est ce que nous rappelle la décision
de la Cour suprême des États-Unis de
juin dernier le droit à l'avortement
qu'on croyait à qui depuis 50 ans
ne l'était en réalité pas du tout
désormais l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse
n'est plus qu'un droit
n'est plus un droit garanti par la
Constitution fédérale des états
et les États fédérés sont donc libres de
l'interdire et pour certains d'entre eux
ils ne se privent pas de le faire
parce que nous avons en effet désormais
la preuve que
aucune démocratie
pas même l'une des plus grandes d'entre
toutes n'est à l'abri il nous faut
rester évidemment toujours
particulièrement vigilant
les auteurs de la présente proposition
de loi madame la Présidente panot
propose d'inscrire le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
dans notre Constitution et j'entends
déjà
murmurait dans un premier temps
et puis s'élever des voix pour dire que
l'exemple américain n'est pas
transposable en France parce que le
droit à l'IVG y est bien protégé il est
vrai que nos institutions fonctionnent
différemment et que le Conseil
constitutionnel français n'est pas la
Cour suprême américaine il est vrai
aussi que le droit à l'IVG a été
conforté au fil des ans depuis qu'il a
été consacré pour la première fois dans
notre droit par la loi Veil du 17
janvier 1975
je pense ici à la dernière loi en date
du 2 mars 2022 porté par votre ancienne
collègue Albane Gaillot qui a allongé le
délai légal pour recourir à les visées
en le portant de 12 à 14 semaines je
pense aussi aux lois qui ont précédé
comme par exemple la loi du 4 août 2014
pour l'égalité réelle entre les hommes
et les femmes qui a supprimé le critère
de la situation en détresse ou encore
avant la loi dite neyers du 27 janvier
1993 qui a dépénalisé l'auto avortement
est créé le délit d'entrave à l'IVG
pour autant
vous le savez gravé dans le marbre de
notre Constitution
le droit fondamental à l'IVG
me paraît plus que nécessaire en ces
temps agités d'abord
cette inscription aurait une valeur
symbolique et bien sûr également
juridique
la constitution et le texte fondateur de
notre État de droit le socle commun des
valeurs et des libertés fondamentales de
notre société inscrire l'IVG dans notre
texte fondamental permettrait de
consacrer comme un droit fondamental et
non simplement comme une liberté
autonomie ensuite
parce qu'il faut bien convenir de cette
évidence changer la constitution et
beaucoup plus difficile que changer la
loi aujourd'hui protéger au niveau
législatif le droit à l'IVG sera demain
protéger au niveau constitutionnel cela
signifie que le législateur ne pourra
pas le remettre
substantiellement en cause seul le
pouvoir constituant le pourrait la
démocratie
l'État de droit et les droits
fondamentaux sont des biens précieux il
est de notre devoir de les préserver
alors ne prenons pas de risques et
protégeons le droit à l'IVG
j'observe
que le droit à l'avortement largement
partagé au sein de l'Union européenne à
toutefois et vous l'avez rappelé madame
la Présidente panot était récemment
remis en question par plusieurs de nos
voisins européens
en Hongrie
par exemple
les femmes ne peuvent plus avorter
sans avoir préalablement dû écouter le
battement de cœur du fœtus
certes il m'est difficile bien sûr de me
mettre à la place des femmes qui
subissent cela mais je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête un instant
dans le silence et le recueillement
peut-être sur la violence inouïe qu'une
telle obligation
inflige aux femmes hongroises
je le dis tout net tant que je serai
garde des sceaux et tant que cette
majorité gouvernera notre pays nous ne
permettrons jamais qu'une telle violence
soit imposée aux femmes françaises
[Applaudissements]
mesdames messieurs les députés
ne vous trompez pas inscrire aujourd'hui
le droit à l'IVG dans notre Constitution
n'est pas une mesure gadget un artifice
de communication ou un mouvement de
panique face à un exemple lointain
inscrire le droit à l'IVG cette liberté
fondamentale et inaliénable de la femme
c'est une sécurité pour toutes les
femmes de notre pays les temps troublés
et les remous ne sont jamais loin dans
le frêle esquif de la démocratie
faites en sorte que nous nous ne la
mendions pas de ne pas avoir sauvegardé
aujourd'hui ce droit fondamental qui
pourrait être remise en cause demain la
nuit dernière se sont encore vous allez
comprendre des dizaines des dizaines
d'amendements de sous amendements qui
ont été déposés
sans répit
et ce alors même que le sujet qui nous
réunit ce matin
particulièrement important
particulièrement gras de quoi
parlons-nous nous parlons du droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps le droit
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
est une condition indispensable à
l'émancipation des femmes sans laquelle
l'égalité
principe absolument cardinal de notre
République en vertu de l'article 2 de la
Constitution ne saurait être pleinement
respecté je répète pour ce messieurs
dames qui produisent des amendements
comme on produirait des gravillons pour
gripper la machine la volonté politique
est là le Gouvernement est favorable à
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution
l'Assemblée nationale je l'espère sera
favorable à l'IVG dans la Constitution
et je ne perds pas espoir avec un
dialogue nourri
et un travail approfondi le Sénat sera
peut-être favorable à l'IVG dans la
Constitution c'est pourquoi je vous le
dis à tous
comme je l'ai dit à vos collègues
sénateurs le mois dernier travaillons
encore
cheminons ensemble afin de mener à bien
cette réforme historique pour dire avec
la plus grande force qui soit aux
générations actuelles et futures de
françaises mesdames votre corps vous
appartient pointe à la ligne
[Applaudissements]
une large majorité de l'hémicycle et
favorable à l'inscription du droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution avec
le soutien d'une partie de la droite et
de l'extrême droite mais certains ont
rassemblement national et chez les
républicains et dénonce un manque de
limite à ce droit alors il dépose des
dizaines et des dizaines d'amendements
faisant ralentir les débats
il y a un vrai paradoxe parce que les
arguments que vous avanchez
effectivement sont des arguments qui
vont en faveur du fait de dire attention
dès qu'on constitutions
et le vrai paradoxe c'est que le comité
veille de 2008 qui s'est penché sur
cette question est-il ou non opportun
inscrire des droits et des principes
fondamentaux nouveaux dans la
Constitution avait répondu par la
négative ce comité était présidé par
Simone Veil elle-même évidemment il
n'était pas spécifiquement cas de l'IVG
mais cette question a été abordée donc
il y a vraiment un débat de fond et je
pense que nous ne devons pas esquiver
les incidences lorsque l'on inscrit
quelque chose dans la Constitution en
fait ce que l'on oublie de dire et ce
qui n'a pas été mentionné ce matin c'est
tout le risque systémique parce que
quand vous inscrivez un droit et bien ce
qui peut se passer on peut en affaiblir
d'autres notamment quand il s'agit de
loi or c'est de cela dont il s'agit
c'est à dire que en réalité il faut voir
l'incidence globale lorsque l'on fait
quelque chose quant à la loi veille ce
que je voudrais rappeler ce qui a été
fait excellemment par notre collègue
Josiane cornegnou il y a quelques
instants c'était de dire que c'est une
loi d'équilibre et cette loi elle avait
un objectif principal c'était évidemment
consacré la liberté de la femme mais
c'était aussi la protection de la vie à
naître et vous voyez bien que cette
question là nous devons bien pouvoir
l'aborder parce que c'est de cela dont
il s'agit est-ce que l'on constitue
analyse un équilibre ou est-ce que l'on
constitutionnalise quelque chose qui
serait déséquilibré c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous portons cet amendement qui
serait une manière de maintenir un
équilibre merci monsieur le député
allez-y chers collègues
moi je voudrais recadrer de un petit peu
le débat voilà j'étais chirurgien je
n'exerce plus mais j'ai connu l'époque
avant 75 et après 1975 je peux vous dire
que remettre en question même de façon
conceptuelle le droit à l'IVG serait une
catastrophe j'ai connu les réparations
j'ai connu les morts j'ai connu les
urgences voilà et donc
il est clair que pour moi ce débat je le
suis depuis ce matin à créer beaucoup
d'émotions et je vous demande d'en tenir
compte ensuite quand j'entends dire que
c'est par un manque de moyens qu'on
pourrait pas actuellement assumer les
demandes d'IVG je pense que c'est un
très mauvais argument parce que dans les
années 80 il n'y avait pas de pénurie du
chirurgien il n'avait pas de pénurie de
structure et les obstacles c'était les
médecins qui ne voulaient pas assumer le
droit de faire des IVG et leur argument
je l'ai vécu c'était de dire je ne suis
pas formé pour faire les IVG alors que
la formation d'un chirurgien bien
entendu permet de faire des IVG donc moi
je vous dis réfléchissez faites
attention c'est un sujet qui peut être
catastrophique parce que la protection
du corps de la femme etc tout ce qui a
été dit c'est fondamental et ça mérite
une inscription dans la Constitution
merci monsieur le député
je vais donc mettre au voile amendement
48 qui a reçu un double avis défavorable
commission et gouvernement le scrutin
est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 272
exprimés 231 majorité 116 pour 35 contre
196 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
nous arrivons avec l'examen de cet
article unique avec les amendements et
sous amendements que nous allons
discuter sur le fond effectivement de
cette proposition de loi
constitutionnelle et la question on va
le voir c'est pas pour ou contre l'IVG
la question c'est bien pour ou contre
l'IVG inconditionnel
on voit bien qu'il y a deux conceptions
et on va pouvoir le voir à travers tous
ces amendements il y a ceux qui font le
droit à l'IVG uniquement sur la liberté
de la femme en disant c'est la liberté
de la femme et à partir de là il y a un
droit qui doit effectivement être
exprimé et qui s'oppose à tout autre
considération il y a une autre
conception qui est celle que nous
défendons qui consiste à dire bien sûr
qu'il y a cette liberté de la femme mais
il y a un autre principe qui est celui
de la Protection de la Vie à être
et qu'il faut trouver cet équilibre cet
équilibre il se trouve difficilement les
débats de la loiveil montrent bien ça
avait été douloureux comme débat mais
c'était à la fois dire oui il y a bien
une liberté de la femme à disposer son
corps c'est pas un droit absolu
et il y a il y a la protection de la
biennette parce qu'effectivement c'est
pour ça qu'il y a un certain nombre de
conditions notamment de délai et la
question que je voudrais vous poser
madame leur rapporteur c'est le ministre
c'est dire pourquoi vous maintenez
encore des conditions de délai si vous
n'êtes incapable de reconnaître la
protection de la Vienne être si vous
êtes uniquement sur la liberté de la
femme rien ne devrait s'opposer à cette
liberté
ni condition particulière comme il
pouvait exister soit ou qui continue à
exister aujourd'hui avec effectivement
ces délais ces délais ils sont là parce
qu'effectivement il y a une
interrogation qui reste un mystère qui
se pose à l'humanité depuis ses débuts
de savoir ce qu'est un embryon ce qu'est
un foetus c'est pas nous aujourd'hui qui
allons y répondre on va continuer à
s'interroger chacun et aussi
collectivement sur ce cette ce mystère
de la procréation mais il faut qu'on
puisse dire oui il y a bien un principe
de protection de la bien-être à côté du
principe de la liberté de la femme je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
l'amendement numéro un madame Ménard
merci madame la Présidente la loi du 17
janvier 1975 sur l'IVG et non dans son
article premier que la loi garantit le
respect de tout être humain dès le
commencement de la vie il ne saurait
être porté atteinte à ce principe qu'en
cas de nécessité et selon les conditions
définies par la présente loi ce principe
législatif était lors du débat de la loi
de 75 un élément essentiel qui avait
conduit à accepter une suspension
c'était le terme qui avait été employée
par l'article 2 de la loi des
dispositions du Code pénal réprimant la
pratique de l'avortement il s'agissait
d'équilibrer les droits de la mer et
ceux de l'embryon en posant une règle
dérogatoire au respect de tout être
humain dès le commencement de la vie
alors si votre proposition de loi
constitutionnelle était votée elle
s'imposerait à cette législation qui
deviendrait en quelque sorte sans objet
c'est l'ensemble de l'édifice législatif
relatif à l'IVG qu'il faudrait modifier
procéder à ces modifications alors que
le recours à l'IVG est en aucune façon
menacée en France je vous rappelle qu'il
y a plus de 220 000 IVG par an en France
sous la pression d'une décision de la
Cour suprême des États-Unis qui n'a
aucun rapport avec le système français
me paraît parfaitement
inutile et dangereux pour notre
Constitution comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le rappeler en discussion
générale mes chers collègues vous agitez
les peurs pour faire croire aux Français
que l'avortement serait menacé en France
quelle imposture citez-moi une décision
du Conseil constitutionnel qui aurait
tenté de le remettre en cause vous n'en
trouverez pas et pour cause il n'y en a
pas c'est pourquoi je demande la
suppression de votre article je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
l'amendement 192 madame Blin merci
madame la Présidente mais cet amendement
de suppression est en réalité un
amendement de cohérence
parce que après avoir modifié l'ordre du
jour au détriment de discussions autour
de la question du pouvoir d'achat que
vous avez refusé de mener dans cette
hémicycle vous avez et vous ne l'assumez
vous ne l'assumerez d'ailleurs
certainement pas
essayez et vous avez trouvé un accord
avec le gouvernement pour réussir à
trouver une nouvelle formulation et
éviter un nouveau débat constitutionnel
la semaine prochaine donc en réalité
vous saviez pertinemment que le
dispositif initialement écrit ne tenez
pas et ne pouvez pas être adopté tel que
donc clairement aujourd'hui voter la
suppression et maintenant la suppression
est tout à fait cohérent sur le fond
vous importez un débat qui vient des
États-Unis alors même qu'en France il
n'est absolument pas question de
remettre
une entrave quelconque à l'IVG la
jurisprudence du Conseil constitutionnel
est tout à fait constante à ce sujet et
d'ailleurs je rappellerai à la à
l'ensemble des élus tenant et peu parti
prenante et fervent défenseur d'Emmanuel
Macron qu'en 2018 Agnès Buzyn Nicole
Belloubet qui était alors ministre avait
affirmé devant le Parlement l'inutilité
d'inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution
en raison de l'extrême solidité de sa
protection constitutionnelle donc
l'amendement de suppression est
aujourd'hui parfaitement opportun merci
madame la députée le 264 Monsieur Le Fur
oui
ça a été dit par ma collègue madame
blinde ça a été dit par Josiane
coeurdonnou également on importe un
débat américain qui n'a rien à voir ici
le débat américain c'est un débat entre
le pouvoir fédéral et le pouvoir des
états ici nous savons un seul
législateur il y a donc pas ce sujet
vous voulez absolument le faire alors
que ce pratique en France 220 000
avortements est-ce que certains veulent
augmenter ce chiffre j'ose espérer que
non donc c'est pas le sujet nous ne
sommes dominés en matière de nombre
d'avortement que par un seul pays
la Russie monsieur Poutine est-ce que
c'est un exemple je crois pas c'est
révélateur surtout des troubles des
difficultés des drames de ce pays donc
nous considérons que cet amendement dans
la Constitution n'est pas nécessaire
qu'il n'est pas souhaité je vous renvoie
également à Simone weilman qui a présidé
une commission constitutionnelle en 2008
et qui avait dit son opposition à la
constitution de l'avortement à la
constitutionnalisation de l'avortement
je vous renvoie à Madame brune Pivet qui
disait la même chose il y a quelques
mois je vous renvoie à Philippe Bas qui
s'est exprimé au Sénat Philippa fut le
collaborateur de Simone Veil il y avait
un équilibre dans les dispositions qui
étaient mises en avant par Simone Veil
il y avait un équilibre dans ce fameux
discours du 26 novembre de 74 que je
vous invite à relire et bien cet
équilibre vous êtes en train de le
casser c'est ça le sujet et c'est pour
ça que nous sommes mobilisés nous
considérons que ces affaires sociétales
ne peuvent pas être prises avec des
slogans mais doivent être prises avec
toutes les précautions nécessaires
merci monsieur le député madame le
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente évidemment je
vais être défavorable assez trois
amendements de suppression et je veux
répondre à certains des arguments qui
ont été avancés et qui seront
ré-avancées madame Ménard vous dites
l'avortement et le droit à l'avortement
n'est pas en danger aujourd'hui en
France et en quelque sorte madame Blin
vous l'avez dit aussi nous sommes en
train d'importer un débat des États-Unis
je voudrais dire d'abord que c'est faux
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord vous avez
raison la jurisprudence du Conseil
constitutionnel va a toujours été en
faveur du droit à l'avortement mais
parce qu'on l'avait saisi sur des sur
des textes qui allaient justement en
progrès sur le droit à l'avortement si
le Conseil constitutionnel était saisi
sur les amendements que vous avez déposé
madame Ménard parce qu'au fond vous
cherchez des prétextes parce que la
question n'est pas est-ce que on veut
inscrire ou pas le droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution pour vous il est étant pour
ou contre le droit à l'avortement c'est
ça que vous êtes en train de poser
pourquoi parce que si le Conseil
constitutionnel était saisi par les
amendements de Madame Ménard qui propose
que le mari ou le compagnon puisse dire
à une femme d'avorter c'est ce que vous
proposez dans vos amendements lorsque
vous pourrez aller vers des questions de
délai vers des questions de réduction
des gratuité et bien je vous le dis ça
peut arriver dans notre pays et nous
avons aujourd'hui dans le groupe de 89
députés rassemblement national des
députés qui sont capables de dire après
avoir génocide les enfants français à
raison de 200000 par an on doit
maintenant les remplacer à tour de bras
par des migrants qui sont capables de
dire de comparer l'allongement de délai
de l'avortement à 14 semaines au
génocide arménien rwandais à la Shoah au
crime de daesh excusez-moi du peu l'IVG
reste un délit donc un acte
intrinsèquement mauvais vous êtes
capable de dire au moment de
l'anniversaire de la loi veille sinistre
anniversaire hommage au million de
victimes de l'avortement non à la
culture de la mort oui à la vie ou
encore l'avortement est un génocide de
masse donc oui aujourd'hui cette
question pourrait se poser si nous la
posons dans la question de la
Constitution c'est parce que nous
pensons le temps long
et le temps long permet justement
d'inscrire une protection supplémentaire
sur la question du droit à l'avortement
qui je crois est nécessaire aussi dans
notre pays surtout quand on regarde ce
qui se passe
compris en Europe je termine sur un
point trouver les prétextes que vous le
souhaitez pour ne pas dire que vous êtes
contre l'avortement mais juste la
question qui est posée c'est est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord pour inscrire
l'avortement je le dis le droit à
l'avortement tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
en termes de délai en termes de gratuité
et autres tel qu'il est aujourd'hui dans
ma constitution où est-ce que en
refusant de l'inscrire dans la
Constitution vous fragilisez le droit à
l'avortement dans notre pays
merci Madame la rapporteur monsieur le
garde des sceaux
[Applaudissements]
et si madame la députée Ménard
légiférer c'était aussi prévoir
mais vous dites c'est un débat
oui bah attendez c'est pas votre tour de
parole vous allez me laisser finir mon
propos si vous le voulez bien
et si Madame Ménard disait avant d'être
interrompu légiférer c'était prévoir
alors vous me dites oui l'Atlantique
nous sépare de tout cela mais pardon de
vous le dire qui sont ici les amis de
Monsieur Trump
qui qui sont les amis de Monsieur Orban
qui pardonnez-moi
pardonnez-moi ont mis un système de
torture qui consiste à obliger les
femmes qui veulent se faire avorter et
pardon de le dire on avorte jamais par
plaisir je suis un homme ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure mais enfin je
pense avoir suffisamment de sensibilité
pour le comprendre on oblige ces femmes
à écouter le cœur battant du fœtus
qu'elle porte dans leur ventre et qui
madame Ménard est proche du gouvernement
italien qui déjà a manifesté un certain
nombre de restrictions quant aux droites
à l'avortement alors prévoir l'avenir
ça n'est pas non plus madame Ménard
regardez le Conseil constitutionnel tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui et en qui les
républicains ont toutes confiance c'est
l'imaginer comme il pourrait être dans
20 ans voyez-vous et pardon de vous dire
qui si ce n'est
l'une des portes-paroles du FN Madame
Laure La Valette a souhaité en 2014
abrogée le droit à l'avortement dans une
tribune qu'elle a signé et enfin ça
vient d'être rappelé quand vous évoquez
les avortements vous parlez de milliers
de victimes alors que chez vous chez
vous on envisage de laisser les migrants
monsieur Odoul mourir de froid à la
frontière polonaise
[Applaudissements]
le rassemblement national défend lui
l'inscription dans la Constitution des
articles du code de la santé publique
qui se rapporte à l'avortement ils
estiment que ce droit n'est pas menacé
en France c'est en tout cas la vie de
Marine Le Pen au début des débats
il y a une vraie malhonnêteté encore une
fois à faire croire que la question est
de savoir si on est pour ou contre la
possibilité de recourir à une IVG c'est
évidemment pas la question qui est ici
posée puisque je le rappelle pour la
énième fois pas un seul mouvement
politique en France représentatif n'est
pour le retrait de cette possibilité
pour les femmes mais il y a un problème
de rédaction non mais vous pouvez hurler
tout ce que vous voulez ça n'y changera
rien
il y a un problème de rédaction dans
votre proposition le problème de
rédaction et le suivant et je crois que
quand on touche à la constitution
effectivement il faut le faire avec une
main tremblante et le problème il est
double il est d'abord que dans la
rédaction que vous proposez il y a une
forme d'inconditionnalité c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a pas de délai ça veut dire
que sur le fondement de votre rédaction
pourrait être réclamé demain d'ailleurs
c'est déjà le cas par le syndrome
d'associations
attention volontaire de grossesse
jusqu'à 9 mois donc à deux mois quatre
mois cinq mois et ça clairement nous y
sommes radicalement opposés pardon et
nous le disons il y a également un
problème car je ne suis pas sûr que
compte tenu de cette rédaction la clause
de conscience des personnels de santé
soient préservés c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vous propose une solution
qui normalement devrait plaire à
l'intégralité de cette hémicycle et qui
consiste à constitutionnaliser la loi
Veil telle qu'elle existe actuellement
c'est à dire les articles du code de la
santé publique qui sont l'intégralité
des articles qui
propose encore une fois cet accès qu'il
le règlemente qui en exprime les
conditions comme ça l'on est sûr qu'il
n'y aura pas dans votre esprit de
régression et nous sommes sur nous qu'il
n'y aura pas une augmentation incons
idérée des délais contre lesquels nous
sommes et vous le savez
après une longue discussion en séance
publique et des amendements aprements
débattus un compromis et finalement
trouvé le député
Erwan balanand député de la majorité et
la chef de fil des insoumises Mathilde
panneaux propose un amendement unique
qui prévoit l'inscription dans la
Constitution de ce droit à l'avortement
en abandonnant le droit à la
contraception
voilà nous avons eu ce matin et en ce
début d'après-midi un débat riche et un
débat je pense qui fait honneur au
travail parlementaire
on avait la chance d'avoir deux
propositions de loi sur le même sujet
proposition de loi de Madame panot et
proposition de loi de Madame berger
quelque part ça nous a donné un temps de
réflexion de travail double temps en
commission et et un travail qui a pu
être fait avec une recherche de
consensus nous nous y sommes arrivés
l'amendement qui a été voté tout à
l'heure qui a un amendement
transpartisan a été voté dans tous les
groupes à la majorité sauf un les
républicains
dans l'ensemble des groupes
majoritairement tout le monde a voté ce
dispositif donc nous montrons par ce
vote notre capacité à travailler
ensemble quand les sujets réclament le
dépassement des clivages et je pense
vraiment que par ce vote par ce travail
nous en aurons le travail nous en aurons
lequel Parlement et nous donnons un
message aussi aux Français c'est-à-dire
que parfois au-delà de nos différences
au-delà de nos contradictions politiques
nous sommes en capacité d'aller dans le
sens
de la réponse la plus proche aux
préoccupations des Françaises et en
l'occurrence sur ce sujet aux
préoccupations des Françaises
la réécriture de cet article unique de
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
vise à convaincre le plus de députés
possible de voter le texte mais elle lui
aussi à convaincre les sénateurs très
réticents à inscrire le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution
encore une fois ce que l'on peut
déplorer c'est que le gouvernement là
dessus a été extrêmement manichéen et
que encore une fois Monsieur le garder
show vous avez utilisé un certain nombre
d'arguments en disant il faut
constitutionnaliser et lorsque l'on
évoque un certain nombre de garanties
nécessaires pour maintenir l'équilibre
qui était vraiment la base même de la
loiveil et bien vous utilisez les mêmes
arguments pour dire le contraire et ça
ça interroge les interrogations
aujourd'hui sont quand même extrêmement
nombreuses et voir aujourd'hui cette
alliance entre la majorité
présidentielle le gouvernement et
évidemment la nu-pêche interroge une
fois de plus pour revenir sur l'écriture
de ce texte je le dirai moi-même c'était
pas mon écriture privilégiée au départ
mais en tout cas c'est aussi le travail
du Parlement que d'être dans leur
recherche d'une voix consensuelle c'est
ce que nous avons fait en tout cas je
crois que avec nous tous ici rassemblés
nous allons pouvoir contribuer à ce
grand pas aujourd'hui vers l'inscription
de ce droit dans la Constitution je
crois que c'est vraiment un jour
extrêmement important pour le droit des
femmes alors maintenant peut-être
monsieur le garder sceau je me tourne
vers vous pour vous dire que nous
comptons sur vous pour que vous puissiez
nous proposer un projet de loi le plus
rapide de monde possible pour que ce
soit vraiment une inscription définitive
dans la Constitution merci à toutes et
tous
nous écologistes aurions bien sûr
préféré une inscription du dispositif
dans l'article 1er de la Constitution et
constitué aussi la contraception ceci
étant l'adoption d'une rédaction commune
est une excellente nouvelle nous en
félicitons réellement en dépit de la
tonalité des débats je le disais c'est
un grand jour il faut mesurer que c'est
un grand jour je souhaite à ce texte une
adoption très large dans cette assemblée
et le même succès demain au Sénat
l'inscription de l'IVG dans la
Constitution est à portée de main je
veux dire au nom du groupe GDR nups
notre émotion et notre fierté notre
conviction juste avant de voter ce texte
qui va permettre la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG on sait
que il y a encore du chemin pour que ce
soit réellement effectif nous sommes
déterminés à mener ce combat pour que ce
texte aille jusqu'au bout
et nous le voyons aussi comme un message
un message de soutien un message comme
un plaidoyer pour l'universalisme de ce
droit et je crois que notre
détermination est bien elle est aussi au
service de toutes ces femmes qui au
travers du monde se battent encore pour
un droit à l'IVG je pense au texane je
pense au hongroise je pense au malgache
aux Italiens et c'est aussi à elle qu'on
dédie ce combat nous nous sommes
évidemment très attachés aux droits des
femmes et alors capacité à décider de
leur vie de disposer de leur corps et
évidemment cette discussion nous
l'attendions avec intérêt étant
conscient que au-delà de la niche LFI la
majorité présidentielle en tout cas le
groupe Renaissance avait prévu de
déposer le texte dans des conditions à
peu près similaires nous l'aurions très
largement très majoritairement voté et
donc nous le ferons aujourd'hui avec
force conscient que les Français en juin
dernier ont souhaité de une
représentation proportionnelle de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui nous
appartient donc en sagesse de créer les
conditions quand cela est possible de
convergence nous nous réjouissons
aujourd'hui que l'ensemble des bancs de
l'Assemblée en tout cas de seuls et ceux
qui ont travaillé à la rédaction de ce
texte et plus particulièrement de
l'amendement qui a permis la convergence
soit en situation d'être largement
majoritaire enfin je veux dire à
certains qui ont usé de faune que nous
vous voyons il aura fallu il aura fallu
deux suspensions de séances au
rassemblement national pour savoir quoi
faire vous avez des colonnes vertébrales
de plastique comme la chef a changé vous
allez changer nous le regrettons mais
nous savons d'où vous venez faisons en
sorte de donner de la force à ce texte
pour qu'au Sénat enfin il trouve éco et
résonance merci à vous
peu avant le vote final la présidente du
groupe Renaissance à l'Assemblée retire
sa proposition de loi qui vise elle
aussi à inscrire le droit à l'IVG dans
la Constitution elle fait cause commune
avec sa collègue de la nupesse
on a tous des héritages des héritages
personnels qui guident nos engagements
et qui doivent normalement guider les
raisons qui font que nous avons eu envie
de devenir parlementaire de nous exposer
et de solliciter le suffrage des
Français la question du combat des
droits des femmes de leur liberté de
leur émancipation a toujours été au cœur
des combats que j'ai menés avant de
revenir dans cette émission puisque je
n'avais pas tout avait prévu d'être là
cet après-midi j'ai appelé une seule
personne qui se trouve être ma maman et
si je vous parle d'elle c'est parce
qu'elle m'a donné l'autorisation de le
faire ma mère a eu recours à
l'avortement à un moment où c'était
illégal dans notre pays
elle y a eu recours comme peut-être un
certain nombre de nos maires de nos
grand-mères elle y a eu recours dans un
moment où elle risquait la prison et
elle risquait sa vie où elle a d'abord
fait appel à un médecin
vraisemblablement assez connu à l'époque
pour cela mais l'opération c'est pas
très bien passée
et comme pour de trop nombreuses femmes
elle a dû ensuite aller à l'hôpital à
l'hôpital où elle pensait trouver un
refuge un refuge bienveillant un refuge
accueillant elle a été reçue sous une
forme d'inquisition parce qu'on avait
bien compris évidemment l'acte qu'elle
avait tenté de réaliser à ce moment-là
et alors alors qu'elle était dans les
mains de médecins et bien ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment là c'est qu'elle a en
effet pu mettre un terme à sa grossesse
mais qu'elle a subi un curetage sans
anesthésie voilà ce qui se passait voilà
ce que les femmes subissaient voilà ce
que nos maires ont pu subir voilà ce que
nos grands-mères ont pu subir
la question de l'accès à l'IVG la
question de sa protection c'est pas un
caprice c'est pas un gain politique
c'est pas une question de groupe
politique les Français on a cessé de le
dire ici ont d'ailleurs fait en sorte
que nous ayons une nouvelle assemblée et
que nous arrivions à démontrer que nous
pouvions travailler différemment c'est
sur la question des droits des femmes
nous ne sommes pas capables de le faire
alors nous serons capables de le faire
sur aucun texte et je crois que c'est la
démarche qu'elle a notre aujourd'hui
alors je le dis très clairement et très
nettement le texte que nous nous
apprêtons à voter et je l'espère avec la
plus large majorité possible aujourd'hui
ce texte là devient le texte de notre
assemblée devient le texte qui doit
toutes et tous nous réunir devient le
texte qui doit pouvoir aboutir parce que
nous ne devons pas finir notre mandat de
parlementaire sans que notre
Constitution ait été modifiée sans que
l'IVG ait été intégré à notre
Constitution c'est ça l'engagement que
nous devons prendre c'est ça
l'engagement que nous prenons
aujourd'hui en votant ce texte
en votant ce texte qui sera le texte
unique sur ce sujet alors je le dis de
manière claire
au nom de toutes les femmes au nom de
toutes nos mères qui se sont battus au
nom de toutes nos filles qui n'ont plus
jamais à devoir se battre je l'espère
oui je suis ici pour cela pour voter ce
texte et j'espère qu'il sera voté de
manière très large aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Pascal bord pour
le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues il nous faut rester
vigilant car nous avons évité le pire
aujourd'hui oui le texte initial qui
était proposé
avait pour objet de créer un droit
inconditionnel à l'IVG et de faire en
sorte que certaines femmes puissent
avorter à 8 ou 9 mois ce qui est
inadmissible et totalement
inenvisageable
ce texte ce texte
marque pour moi une défaite cuisante de
la gauche de cette gauche radicale et
radicalisée qui n'a pour boussole que la
fin de notre monde la fin du monde tel
que nous le connaissons
c'est grâce effectivement un travail
trans partisan c'est grâce à
l'amendement de Marine Le Pen que la
majorité que la majorité a réécrit
rapidement très rapidement son texte
texte qui sera soumis dans quelques
instants au vote c'est devant devant
effectivement cette réécriture
cette réécriture qui qui est un moindre
mal Marine Le Pen a effectivement retiré
son amendement
le texte le texte voté
ne change rien en termes de droit
puisqu'il renvoie à la loi mais ça n'est
pas je vous le rappelle une protection
absolue c'est la raison pour laquelle il
nous faudra rester de tout temps
extrêmement vigilant ce texte je vous
disais est un moindre mal
l'ensemble des groupes s'est en exprimé
je vais mettre au bois le texte de la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
résultat du scrutin votant 387 exprimé
369 majorités 185 pour 337 contre 32
l'Assemblée nationale a adopter la
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
la proposition de loi constitutionnelle
est largement votée ce 24 novembre 2022
une unanimité saluée par celle qui a
porté le texte Mathilde panot
collègue je suis très très émue à la
fois de ce vote et de ce signaler
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore a
envoyé à toutes les femmes de notre pays
mais aussi à l'ensemble des femmes du
monde
je suis très émue de voir que malgré
l'obstruction qui n'en a pas terminé
jusqu'à son terme nous avons su dégager
collectivement un consensus avec la
conscience du temps long persuadé que
nous faisons acte de progrès pas
seulement pour nous-mêmes mais aussi
pour les générations à venir
aujourd'hui collègue l'Assemblée
nationale par le monde aujourd'hui
collègues notre pays parle au monde
la France en introduisant le droit à
l'avortement dans la Constitution serait
la nation pionnière en matière des
droits des femmes il est temps que notre
pays s'affirme comme à l'avant-garde de
la protection des droits sexuels et
reproductifs monsieur le ministre
maintenant la balle est dans le camp du
gouvernement nous espérons et nous
sommes nombreuses à l'espérer nous
espérons un projet de loi
constitutionnel qui nous permettent
d'aller plus rapidement sur cette
question
je veux ici remercier chaleureusement et
sincèrement l'ensemble des collègues
députés qui ont permis de recueillir la
sentiment de leur groupe et de
travailler à cette formulation
transparisane je remercie Mélanie Vogel
qui courageusement au Sénat a porté
cette question il y a un mois je
remercie évidemment l'administrateur
monsieur Joly mais l'ensemble aussi des
services de l'assemblée qui ont fait un
travail remarquable je veux enfin dédier
cette victoire historique que nous
envoyons à la fois comme signal à notre
pays mais au monde aux femmes des
États-Unis aux femmes de Pologne aux
femmes de Hongrie dont le droit à
l'avortement et aujourd'hui on travaille
mais aussi et elles sont là aujourd'hui
aux militants qui dans notre pays
lutte au quotidien pour le droit des
femmes à disposer de leur corps je vous
remercie
merci
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais d'abord m'associer aux mots
qui viennent d'être dit par les
différents orateurs et notamment par la
rapporteur sur le message historique que
la France délivre à la phase du monde et
principalement quand on connaît les
attaques que nous avons rappelé
principalement quand on connaît aussi
notre histoire puisque c'est 50 ans
après le procès de Bobigny j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire au début de cette
discussion ce que je voudrais vous dire
aussi
c'est ce que nous de beauté ce n'est pas
le point final
et ce que nous avons fait nous pouvons
le faire y compris sans attendre un
projet de loi du gouvernement c'est pour
ça qu'il était aussi essentiel aussi
essentiel
de réécrire le texte que vous nous
proposiez
d'être parfois un peu plus prudent même
si nous ne renonçons à rien sur la
contraception c'est pour ça qu'il était
aussi essentiel de pouvoir inscrire ces
dispositions dans le corps même de la
Constitution et non seulement en son
article premier et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons ouvert la voie
à un débat dans la haute chambre un
débat qui nous implique tous puisque
auprès des groupes
qui nous représentent également auprès
de cette chambre nous avons une
responsabilité un débat qui nous
implique tout et pour lequel je prendrai
ma part en prendront notamment à tâche
avec le président de la commission des
Lois du Sénat pour que ce texte chemine
et je vous invite vraiment à considérer
qu'il ne s'agit là en dépit du fait
qu'il s'habite un grand pas que d'un
premier pas je vous remercie
merci la
parole merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés
je prends acte avec beaucoup de
solennité de gravité du vote historique
qui vient d'avoir lieu il y a de cela
quelques minutes
j'ai tout à l'heure dans mon discours
appelé de mes vœux que l'Assemblée
nationale se prononce pour l'inscription
de l'IVG dans notre Constitution
c'est désormais chose faite et bien
faite avec une très large majorité
le texte est adopté par le Sénat le
premier février 2023 mais les sénateurs
ont réécrit l'article unique qu'ils ont
remplacé la notion de droit par celle de
liberté désormais la loi détermine les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce la
liberté de la femme de mettre fin à sa
grossesse le 8 mars journée
internationale des droits des femmes
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé un projet de
révision constitutionnel cette
proposition de loi pourrait devrait en
faire partie c'est la fin de ce numéro
des grands débats à bientôt sur LCP
[Musique]